you may have heard of Kentucky route
zero there's been quite a bit of buzz
about it because it is now officially
released and you may have no idea what
this game is or it was a game that you
heard of eight years eight years ago but
that's why we're here to tell you
because about this game because we think
it is pretty rad I'm joined by Ben Janka
hello and Corrine Davina hi I'm John
Luke and yeah this is Kentucky route
zero Kurt you I'd say you're the the
most aggressively in things yes yeah I
would I would I would say the same and
what an honor it is so Kentucky route
zero is unabashedly my one of my
favorite games of the decade hmm and
it's hard to say that because the game
has only just been completed in the
sense that it's been released in several
acts over a span of many many years and
now we finally have the concluding act
of Kentucky route zero so what even is
this game yeah yeah this game if I could
say it in the simplest terms is a sure
real fantasy folklore story about a man
and his journey to drop off his final
delivery and it just so happens that his
final delivery is in a place that
requires him to take a mysterious route
just simply known as zero huh but when I
try to explain the game to people I try
to say that it is best explained as an
interactive movie script so it's not so
much a interactive novel as it is you go
through these conversations like we're
seeing here and you get to make subtle
choices on how that story is told
nothing that has huge consequences in
the end but it's it's it shapes the way
you play this kind of grounded folklore
story blue so in this case yeah we can
name our dog Homer
blue
or just some dog I don't know his name
that's what I chose the first yeah that
is something I remember really just blue
when I first played this a decade ago
and I think that's probably one of the
most important things that bring up and
say is that this game is has been in
development and released in fragments
over many many years and it's very hard
to get people on board with this game
knowing that it's not finished which is
what makes now so great because it's
like hey it's finally done you tell here
you can just play from start to finish
it's on every system we're playing it on
PC with a controller but it's like
switch ps4 Xbox like it's everything
right right and the thing that I adore
about this game I mean right here just
from the start it has the most I just
love this art style it's this
minimalistic kind of graphic designers
wet dream of a pop-up book video game is
I kind of like to describe it as a
pop-up book the way things moving in and
out yeah and here is a lot of it is
mostly dialog that is the gameplay
element is conversations in dialogue and
here for example as well as getting to
at earlier where you can make choices
but they don't really have massive
incomes it's kind of outcomes it's more
of the the story you want to tell with
the characters you're playing as so here
we're learning about Conway who's not
necessarily the main character but he's
the character that introduces us to this
world and this dog would drive he needs
to get to to deliver this last antique
item for his delivery service that he
works for and here during this segment
is like the very tiptoe intro to this
mysterious route that you can't quite
see or go to everything is this kind of
underlying surrealist tone to it
wherever didn't make sense though
nothing does at all
yeah
so really the idea that you you
mentioned that it's kind of like you're
you're writing your own script mm-hmm
that I didn't think about it that way oh
this this transistor yeah this is the
pop-up book thing I was kind of talking
about and how this these things kind of
unravel and create and then the basement
people the basement people and this is
the and I'm sorry Ben we'll get back to
this great but this kind of feeds into
this surreal element where I talked to
these people I can choose what I want to
say it's like Oh have you seen the
breaker box down here sorry I didn't
know there was anyone down here in any
case they they don't even notice you
they don't even know you're there but
it's never explained it just simply is
just accept it and that's what it is and
that's the I compared a lot to the
folklore writer Gabriel Garcia Marquez
who writes very grounded surrealist
fantasy work and I think he is probably
the most a most poignant example of
literature that you can compare to a
game like this but you were saying like
an interactive movie script and that's
kind of how I the best way I can kind of
explain to people and also this is very
Americana feel that I kind of always
like to bring up too because the music
elements I think are just as important
to the aesthetic of the game as the art
style itself yeah I appreciate it's
something that you kind of like over
time the the subtlety of the the the
choices you make where it's it's
completely different from like a Mass
Effect or a Bioware game where it's like
big sweeping you know this is gonna
write you know everyone's gonna have a
different ending and it's more just like
the small subtleties like I named the
dog blue and it's gonna be named blue
for the rest of the game exactly like I
by saying blue like I think I could be
wrong but it was like when you said blue
it said her name so like you're actually
also picking the gender of the dogs well
like like very subtle storytelling but
it
yeah just it works and it has invoked
that same feeling of like I'm affecting
this story and I'm having like agency in
it it's and that's the thing that I
really and that's like the part of it
that I adore in the sense that it's you
don't you're not making huge massive
choices you are guiding your own story
along just with your own kind of taking
flavor and when it comes to why this
game is important is that there simply
is nothing like this and at the time of
which it came out and I also think
what's so interesting is that a game
that isn't that it's only just finished
has had influences on other games
oh right for games like oxen-free which
I think has a very similar style in a
very similar way of which conversations
unravel however this game wasn't even
done by the time oxen-free came out as a
completely finished game yeah I mean I
didn't think about that but like yeah
just the the the way the simplistic
polygons the use of lighting there's an
obvious style this game has such a
distinct style that it's almost hard not
to associate games that came after it
with this game even though this game was
not finished and let alone by like three
people right yeah yeah so this is one of
the examples where I can talk to them
about the people downstairs and Joseph
this this kind of everyone has this very
like Airy kind of calm old man quality
to them okay it's a it's a very relaxing
game it is music is is this like droning
swelling synth
yeah like bender score you kind of like
almost when I first played it you you're
like waiting for the moment or it
becomes like a horror game almost you're
like oh it's so yes like you're waiting
for like this creepy unease to happen
and there's there's moments of like
you're not really sure what's going on
but it's not it's not trying to be scary
yes yeah so this is a great a great time
where you kind of choose nothing you do
is the wrong
so Joseph needs me to go to his computer
to unlock a way to get to this address
that I need to get to that apparently I
need to take the route for but he
doesn't know how to get to the route and
this is one of those beautiful moments
where you have the opportunity to kind
of just tell the game what you think the
password is even if it is or isn't right
by you doing so it becomes that thing
and I just love some of these this is
the part where this balance of the game
has like these weirdly poetic moments
that you can just kind of choose and you
kind of have now creating a poem as a as
the dude's password him talking a fellow
Grim Fandango fan I love the opportunity
to create the poem a game the moon
throbs oh man all of us here are like
huge point clicking yes and I think
that's like another thing for me is that
adventure games kind of exists now but I
feel like they most importantly exist in
a different way than they once did and I
think that's mine as in we don't really
focus so much on puzzles but Moore's
though the thing I think people took
away from adventure games later down the
road was its story and it's characters
story Carrie and I think this is this
games an excellent kind of continuation
I I loved grim fandago but I would
happily play version of that game where
I actually don't have to solve a puzzle
and I just do yeah like die Allah I yeah
I mean it's just because the they are
the conversation and the dialogue is so
so good and this game is kind of a
similar way that the conversations are
quirky and weird and bizarre and you
don't have to deal with a lot of
gameplay mechanics in the way
but this game is an experience for sure
I'm really excited to go because I
literally had only played like the first
act when it first happened yeah and I
haven't touched it since so this is this
is just reminding me of like subtly of
what I vaguely remember mm-hmm and I'm
actually kind of getting a little antsy
like go back and play it again yes and
something else that's so just marvelous
about how this game is rolled out is
that in between each act there's these
interludes that you can play on PC
they're not a part of the full package
you actually have to go to the website
to download to the cardboard computer
website to download them or there's ones
where you there's actual phone numbers
that you can call I remember the phone
with your cell yeah like I know it
sounds stupid be like you can call with
their cell phone but it's it's just a
fascinating thing because we usually
don't have to go out of our way to call
a phone line and then use the numbers on
our touchpad to figure out certain
scenarios and certain things but this
game takes advantage of all of those
which gives it a really unique kind of
nostalgia in a way do you say the
interludes are on the console version
yes so the console version has them in
sequential order so you can choose to
play them as they were intended or you
can just go ahead and skip to the next
act if you like but in the game's
brilliance everything in some way means
something and the broader scheme of
things even though nothing entirely
seems to make sense yet like I said
earlier it all does yeah in in the rules
of the Kentucky route zero universe yeah
this the whole feel of all of this just
makes me think about it
yeah I like to kind of associate
different types of games with playing
like at different times of day or during
different types of like I'm feeling this
feels like a very good like I'm really
tired after a long day at work it's
actually really late and I've gotten
everything done and out of the way and I
just want to relax and play a game from
like 11 p.m. until like 2 a.m. in the
morning yes that's that's what this game
feels like to me
ah this game makes me want to take like
a road trip
oh yeah Erica and then I stopped at my
motel for the night and then I pull out
my laptop and I play a Act of Kentucky
route zero oh there you go I I'm just
ready to go head northeast on sixty five
journal left as you see the ugly tree I
turn the wrong way the ugly tree that's
always on fire there we go that's the
one and that's and again that's like the
thing I keep talking about that's
certain things are very illogical but
always make sense in this place we're
already in a scene to what's happening
and this isn't a terribly long game each
act so what's interesting is Act one is
it is maybe about an hour and a half two
hours right and they see they get longer
as time goes on and as we mentioned this
game came out fragmented over many many
years which is equally a criticism of it
and a fault of it here's some of this
beautiful pop up
art design and sewins
things coming into focus but the game
took years to make and came out what was
always intended as five acts and you can
definitely tell as you play the acts
back-to-back how they tend to get longer
and they tend to get a little bit more
involved which i think is a testament of
the process of these people developing
the game and their first game for that
matter
that's gotta be so hard to work on a one
singular game for like ten years and
yeah it's like you it's not even just
like you get tired of it it'd be like
the the scope of what you want to do
with it would change but you're like we
got a still have it be cohesive like is
so amazing about this game is that all
these years later and having played it
just recently back to back to back is
how holistic the vision was from start
to finish the and it's just one of those
experiences that it's hard to have
pitched to someone at the time of which
these were coming out so I think all of
us in this room have played at least
some of the acts at some point and may
have started even when the game first
came out the first act came out all
those years ago but trying to tell
something like it's not out yet it's not
done yet and I think a lot of people
right now have just been waiting for
this moment for all of them to come out
for all of them to be on console so if
there's any time to finally play this
game this right now now it's nice the
best is Hyatts this is it this is your
call to action it's and the one thing
that I adore about this game is that it
teeters this almost kind of artsy indie
thing that was quite booming in the in
the early 2000s but still maintains a
lot of quirkiness and whimsy kind of
nature's to it I often compare it also
to like the Americana feels of like Coen
brother films and how those like the
soundtrack is so and involved with the
start and finish and feel and aesthetic
of those movies so I just so we picked
the right person to come on in try to
tell people about it yeah I said I
remember like we should we should start
this up who we doing this it's gotta be
Kurt
such an honor who sent you that that
that cool text over slack and we're like
a hey Kurt hey hey I think I just said
yes yeah you just you're just like yep
whatever it is guess so and I kind of I
it sounds like kind of wanker II to be
like it's so poetic but there is a
visual just kind of poetry voice below
that just is is pleasing to watch as it
is to read and to listen to one thing we
don't really get to see in the first act
but the thing that I also adore is how
seamlessly conversations change so
you'll be talking with another character
for example and before you know it
you're choosing that character dialogue
choices in the conversation play yes I
think act you starts again it does it in
such a seamless way where you're just
kind of telling this story from all
angles however which way you want it to
be told and it's just it's so dreamy
that you don't even notice that it's
happening yeah I had just to love it say
this this music is doing a lot of
lifting and definitely helping making
bend rabbit if you did the soundtrack
for this deserves a massage he'll
personally go to his house and give a
sense and Babbitt Kurt I'm here the
massager for the massage and if you're
listening to this and you have in San
Francisco please let me know I will
squeeze your shoulders hit your boy up
he's got you but I he is one of the core
names to the development of this game
which I find interesting cuz he's solely
just the soundtrack he's the music but I
feel like that as as I've said many
times just as much of a character and
just as much of a trademark gene there
is no most the time that's just all
you're hearing it's just the soundtrack
so the ongoing mystery of this game the
person we just met is now gone yes
insane yeah definitely a lot of ghosts
and a lot of it kind of always and as
the game goes on there's is those though
nothing makes sense things do seem to
come together things are coming together
admittedly I have not played the final
act so it is hard for me to say
how this if it concludes in a satisfying
way but through the journey of the many
many many characters you meet and get to
control ah this is a beautiful scene oh
that's so good to hear and watch this
this mysterious bandages hanging out in
a barn across the street is this thing
you wouldn't expect at all you're just
like I'm walking back to my horror
what's going on yeah moments like this
is where I think the game really and
this game has lots of them oh my gosh
yeah and just talk to blue there's it's
you know the the the song in act 3 I
remember everyone talking about it one
and for anybody who doesn't know that
it's the most defining scene of this
entire game that I think really
encapsulates what makes this game so
special in terms of visuals music the
ability to choose and kind of fabricate
this story yourself in a way that it's
your own right now I'm just talking to
blue and blues listening yeah all that
matters yeah you're literally talking to
a dog about what you just saw yeah he
has nothing to say but he's he's there
to listen and every character talks to
him you can every character can talk to
blue or home or whatever it is you
decide the name of a dog and they just
listen that dog just listens thank you
good dog but a good dog no I like the
name blue that's a good name for a dog
yeah first time I chose no name and then
I and then I chose Homer for my second
playthrough she's a part of me that
thinks like if you pick us just some dog
it there's like more there's more
mystery there's a story behind that like
we're going home from how to get here I
mean he does say that he does add on to
why that dog doesn't have a name well I
think this is about a pretty good taste
of Kentucky route zero is there anything
else you want to add Kurt Ben
I'm excited slate again play this game
yeah even if even if it's not it's it's
one of those it's it's I consider it one
of those things even if you get it or
you don't
it owes your time and attention to at
least appreciate its existence in the
realm of this medium so even if you guys
end up hating and you hate reading
that's fine I get it but I do think this
is one of those defining titles that
nothing was really like it before and I
think it's gonna be a very long time
until we see something like it again and
therefore it's worth it yeah worth you
knowing about absolutely agree yeah it
is available now on all platforms which
is great like you can get the whole
experience and one go which is probably
the pretty great you don't have to wait
the way we did for for almost a decade
much different experience for anybody
who gets to play them start to finish
that way yeah I'm actually really
curious how that experiences for
somebody but yeah this game seems
interesting you please check it out I
think all of us here can highly
recommend it definitely enough yes thank
you for watching thank you thank you
thank you thank thank you thank you
thank thank you thank blue they blue oh
what a good boy